in 2003 SpongeBob SquarePants Battle for
Bikini Bottom was released and became a
touchstone for a generation of children
already obsessed with the cartoon while
Nostalgia plays a large factor I like
many people around my age hold that game
in high regard even if the experience
doesn't quite hold up all these years
later now two decades later SpongeBob
SquarePants The Cosmic Shake has been
made as a spiritual successor and for
better and for worse it plays the way I
remember Battle for Bikini Bottom I'm
ready I'm ready I'm ready
I forgot something I forgot something
now I'm really ready now I'm really
ready in Cosmic Shake SpongeBob and
Patrick stumble upon a mermaid named
Cassandra who sells antique and
mysterious items SpongeBob purchases
bubble soap that supposedly grants
wishes running around town and asking
everyone he knows for their wishes
unfortunately all of The Wishes kick in
at once tearing holes in reality and
sending the citizens of bikini bottom
off into the Multiverse with SpongeBob
and Patrick left to pick up the pieces
the opening sets up Seven Levels players
will explore throughout the game each
one with a different theme and
environment the aesthetic design of
these levels is one of the few places
the cosmic Shake shines pulling together
references to iconic episodes of the
show while adding new elements that fit
within the game's story a movie set
themed episode combines SpongeBob's
obsession with karate with an action
movie and a pirate level has an enemy
ship constantly firing pie bombs at you
as for where the cosmic Shake pulls most
of its inspiration from it stems almost
exclusively from the older seasons of
SpongeBob is it too much ask for just
one day of peace and quiet how am I
supposed to paint my newest Masterpiece
with you two clowns constantly giggling
in my ears I wish that Squidward will
finally be appreciated for his art well
the show is still airing many of the
references made through the game are
from Seasons I watched as a child and
easily could have appeared in Battle for
Bikini Bottom 20 years ago there are a
few nods to the modern seasons of the
show specifically Plankton's pet spot
who serves as a collectible in each
level but the majority of its jokes and
callbacks are old school most of these
references feel well placed and don't
overstay their welcome with one major
exception that exception is the caveman
level where SpongeBob and Patrick are
sent back to the prehistoric era to try
to save Squidward this pulls directly
from the episode SB 129 karate Choppers
in season 1 where Squidward ends up time
traveling to both the past and future
and the past language hasn't been
invented yet so everyone speaks in
gibberish what works as a small section
of a half hour card tune overstays its
welcome here and most levels SpongeBob
and Patrick are frequently commenting on
the level spouting off jokes that mostly
land but here it's an hour to 90 minutes
of caveman speak which really kills the
game's momentum as for the design of the
levels the cosmic Shake takes a far more
linear approach than Battle for Bikini
Bottom and this mostly Works in its
favor the levels have a bit of width to
them allowing you to explore off the
beaten path to find extra Cosmic jelly
which you are tasked with collecting
throughout the game but beyond this
small amount of Freedom this focus on a
more linear setup allows for the
platforming to shine since there is a
single defined path that can be
purposefully designed around the
movement skills that have been unlocked
so far SpongeBob comes equipped with a
double jump out of the gate but is
quickly given far more movement
abilities throughout the game making for
fluid platforming these movement
abilities make SpongeBob feel fast when
they are all working together and the
sections that ask you to use them
altogether feel incredibly satisfying
you gain abilities like a Glide a karate
kick a ground pound and even a grappling
hook Doling out a new ability in most
levels means there is always a new
mechanic to keep the game fresh and it
provides a way to hide secrets in each
level for you to come back to levels
require you to platform through them
eventually needing to find a number of
objects to move further these sections
usually have an arena-like area where
you can choose which direction to start
in for your collecting but always end up
in the same destination it's a nice
break from the more linear platforming
sections and these sections never
overstayed their welcome where the
linear Design Falls flat is in the
game's secret optional objectives as for
combat you use your new abilities to
fight off Cosmic Jelly Monsters there
are a number of different types of Jelly
Monsters and each one has a specific way
to beat it unfortunately as time goes on
this becomes a tedious task especially
with enemies where you have to wait for
an opening for example the large enemies
carrying bathtubs require three hits to
take down but they only take damage
after missing an attack on You by the
time you fight one of these for the 10th
time it becomes more tedious to wait and
hit it which is true for other enemy
types as well there is far more
platforming than combat in the cosmic
Shake but long battles especially late
in the game feel like a chore each level
caps off with a boss fight of some kind
with the exact format of the battle
changing from level to level the opening
Western level concludes with you chasing
Mr Krabs through a train while battling
enemies and the movie level concludes
with a showdown against Sandy none of
these are particularly challenging but
they are all different and short enough
to be enjoyable and my mood is
thank you
nobody watches a film for the dialogue
with a linear design and unlockable
movement abilities going off the main
path to find a secret can have mixed
results sometimes you find a golden
Doubloon which is needed to unlock Extra
costumes and it feels rewarding many
times though you find a side objective
that is locked behind an ability you
don't have yet which can feel
frustrating in the moment this is
obviously meant to get you to come back
through each level after beating the
game but replaying levels is where the
cosmic Shake really starts to flounder
since each level is linear replaying
them can feel like a slog there are
checkpoints that you can choose to start
from in each level but the game doesn't
tell you where the Collectibles are just
that you're missing them this means that
you realistically need to run through
the level from start to finish unless
you remember exactly where all the
secrets were when you couldn't reach
them and if you miss one on that second
run through your only choice is to go
for a third there are some new
challenges and sections added after
completing the game but not enough to
justify a full second run through any
level
terrible what happened Mr Dutchman that
son of a kill Peter Admiral Tron has
stolen me beloved who is it broccoli
ahead never mind it's just a Flying
Dutchman while playing The Cosmic Shake
is certainly fun its Collectibles and
unlockables leave a lot to be desired
for one particular reason there is no
point in collecting them while it is
part of the game and platforming is fun
enough to make the process enjoyable the
rewards are often lackluster one of the
main mechanics is that with each new
Multiverse level SpongeBob is given a
new costume to help him fit into the
environment in addition to those
costumes you can also purchase more
using Cosmic jelly you collect after
unlocking them by finding enough gold
doubloons the problem here is that the
costumes don't Impact gameplay in any
way so the novelty wears off quickly
it's cool to spot an outfit that
SpongeBob wore in a specific episode but
without any impact on the game itself
they just aren't that interesting in
addition to those disappointing costumes
the other Collectibles aren't needed for
anything else the game tells you to
collect Cosmic gel belly but you don't
need it to advance from level to level
If an item isn't a part of the main
objective in a level there is zero need
or incentive to collect it once I
realized this in the last few levels I
began ignoring optional platforming
challenges that only appeared to reward
Cosmic jelly since it didn't feel worth
my time
despite a few hiccups and disappointing
aspects of the cosmic Shake design at
its core it achieves its goals playing
it felt the way I remember Battle for
Bikini Bottom playing and all of the
jokes and references felt aimed at older
SpongeBob fans pulling from the classic
episodes there are tons of small jokes
and references in the levels that will
make you smile and SpongeBob and Patrick
will have you at least chuckling more
often than not it's not a revolutionary
platformer but it's good enough to keep
you engaged throughout the entire game's
length if you have no reverence or
appreciation for SpongeBob whether it be
the old games or the cartoon the cosmic
Shake likely won't appeal to you but for
those of us who love SpongeBob The
Cosmic Shake is a great time with some
old friends
[Music]
cool kids
I wish I could do cool things
I swearing just dominously appeared out
of nowhere who cares